as many of you know hopefully digital
wellness
big priority for Google this year and
because technology is becoming a bigger
and bigger part of everyone's lives what
we often hear from users today though is
that they want to find a better way to
find a better balance with the
technology that they use and love every
day especially with their phones so is
play an Android from a platform an
operating system perspective we
obviously believe that it's our
responsibility to build products for
users that make their lives easier and
better and not detract from them as you
can imagine on the games team over the
past year we've been thinking a lot
about these trends and core values at
large especially in relation to how they
translate to our work with game
developers in the game space and what's
interesting about the game space and why
I wanted to start off this panel talking
about wellness is that often when it
comes to games the idea of mindfulness
and sustainability can sometimes be at
odds now I want to be clear when I talk
about mindfulness I mean mindfulness in
terms of more meaningful user engagement
and they can often feel 'god's
we're all going after people's time
their money user mind share but how do
you pursue deep engagement without
necessarily causing burnout and how do
you pursue more meaningful monetization
without necessarily causing buyer's
remorse and how do you do both of these
things well while also achieving your
business objectives obviously that
balance is a really difficult one to
strike but when I personally think about
a developer who has proven that bottom
lines and mindfulness don't necessarily
have to be at odds who actually
intentionally uses more meaningful
engagement and more sustainable
monetization as a strategy to achieve
their impressive business goals
I think of crowd star so I am very
excited to have a group of people here
from crowd star today we're gonna join
me up on stage in a second to tell us a
little bit more about their approach to
gaming in general what makes them
different and how they believe these
differences have played into their
success in the market in recent years
and helped them build very healthy and
sustainable businesses okay let's talk
about to say
okay well let's first do some
introductions chris hi i'm chris McGill
I'm the general manager of design home
I'm Sarah Fuchs I'm the general manager
of covet fashion thank you guys for
joining us it's a pleasure
great let's kick it off so creative
fashion and interior design games Chris
will you tell us a little bit about how
you and your team approached creating
these games in this space I think the
crib notes are really about crowd star
so crowd star just quickly has been
several different companies and in a
moment of desperation when Facebook
changed policies when they were gonna
run out of money sometimes that moment
of desperation about six years ago
unleashes you from the rules and prior
to me the covenant fashion came about
when they had no time left and they
decided to take it just a radical
different approach because there's no
downside and what they did is instead of
a fail fast game environment they
actually look for the white space tried
to figure out who has not served and
took this crazy chance of not only
creating an entertaining game but one
they could have intrinsic value in your
life outside the game and that's you
know design home iterated on that and
it's its own entity but it's the same
principle of entertaining people with
about the things that they love but also
having a connection to what you do and
how you do it and make your life more
informed outside of the game it's really
an app and a game and it worked
yeah so five years later I'm inside I
can tell you I mean how the fashion is
having its record year you know and home
it's a top 30 grossing awesome
well obviously crowd star has carved out
this very interesting space for itself
to work in in terms of its innovative
and atypical game design but what is it
that you think makes these games so
unique and successful Sarah I think we
meet the players where they are I think
we have thought about
you know what women like to do and found
a way to make that fun and make that a
game and make that interesting and we
spend a lot of time learning about our
players and I think the more we get to
know our players and the more we think
about what emotion we want our players
to have when they're playing and when
they're done playing and when they make
a purchase we really think about the
experience that's valuable for them and
we want them to come away with this
positive feeling and so we use that as
kind of a North Star for how we design
our games it's a strong player first
kind of mentality play our first 100%
another thing that's really interesting
about card star I think in terms of the
game are sorry about covet and design
home in terms of games and is this
intrinsic reward aspect of your games
we've expanded on that a little bit sure
I mean we we want players to play we
don't we don't necessarily use kind of
tried-and-true game mechanics we have we
are event based and so we provide five
to six events every day and players come
in and they they have a whole cup of
fashion they have a model that they
dress and then they get voted on and
they get to enjoy the rewards from that
so we don't have sort of necessarily
extrinsic rewards for them they come
back and they are passionate about what
they do and one thing that has stuck
with me and some of our conversations is
that your players are actually happier
when they're done playing covet or
playing design home that's pretty
unusual I would say yeah there's
actually a study that shows a year later
in covent fashion that women are happier
because it's a you don't put yourself
into the game it's not about you or your
body your face you actually get to learn
what you like what you don't like and a
year later when you step out of your
house whether you're going on a date and
a job interview or out with the
girlfriends you feel a little more
confident about yourself
so you know you know we try to be
additive to our players lives and we try
to measure that to you I mean you can't
measure happiness that's impossible if
we could do that that would be like the
secret sauce but we do try to engage
with our players as often as we possibly
can to understand what makes them happy
we send random surveys how did you like
this challenge we pull them at random
times we have a style Council on covet
fashion that has 25,000
that we that we talk to you on a regular
basis we make videos for them we give
them feedback we give them exclusive
access and we really want to take what
our players have to say and make sure
that we're delivering the experience
that's right for them it's a balance of
you know heavy heavy quant but also tied
in with a lot of pong so obviously this
user centric kind of strategy is can
something that you've stayed very tied
to you know I think you said these
businesses kind of grew out of seizing
the white space that was available but
you've clearly stayed very tied to your
players how much does that continue to
drive the growth and evolution of these
games I think it's everything it's the
reason why we get out of bed I mean we
have to have a love affair with our
users like you have to understand them
quantitatively in the game we have to
understand them qualitatively in the
game but also in their lives and the
idea is we actually write down the
emotions that we want you to feel when
you play the game but also the emotions
you want to feel when you close the game
so they're not just entertained but just
then find an hour later you close the
app and you're like another hour older
okay so using user sentiment to guide
the in design obviously makes sense
and but as you mentioned sir it's all
it's really tricky and how do you guys
balance between optimizing for user
sentiment against optimizing and for key
business KPI is like engagement or
revenue you do this one okay so
obviously we're thinking about KPIs
but when we're designing a new feature
we'll make sure we stop and think you
know is this a retention KPI is it is a
retention feature is this an engagement
feature is this a revenue feature and we
really think about that and often you
know we are in the midst of designing
this fantastic engagement feature that's
coming soon but and you know as we're
designing we think oh my gosh we could
totally monetize the crap out of this
totally make money here and then we're
like you guys know that's not what this
is about we want to engage our players
it's about the long game for us it's not
about that
instant buck like we could have a sale
tomorrow and you know have a
million-dollar day but that the hangover
for that would be so just not worth it
so we really think about
you know the long game for our players
and get and breath as many players as we
possibly can you know paying a little
bit but enjoying their time and that is
how to maximize revenue for us I mean
that is it's not like Oh altruism you
know we're still about the business but
it's a question of like we're trying to
build a platform a long-standing
platform that never wears out and so
it's a matter of what you do and when
you do it and these are I mean we have
these fights all the time though
internally and lastly we have not not me
and Sarah it's really what we're talking
about it's like okay well you know we
could put in this feature and we know
like we leave money on the table short
term money every day in the interest of
long-term money and that's the balance
that we have to argue about in a healthy
way every day like okay look we know
this month you know we can make an extra
two million dollars but you know that's
gonna lead to retention issues and
that's actually not going to enrich
their lives and we also make sure I mean
the stuff that I'm most proud of is
actually the percentage of our payer
base so every day we have a million
women in the game and at any given point
forty percent of them have been payer
right so it's about having a broad and
engaged audience that doesn't pay a ton
like we're like the anti whale hunters
and we don't like the term whale we we
don't you we don't use the term whale
except to say we don't use the term oil
right I'm sorry I said well so it sounds
like for our monetization perspective I
want to dive into the engagement
perspective piece in a second about
what's something that Chris just said
but from a monetization perspective it
sounds like your North Star is getting
users to pay small amounts over time so
there's a consistency aspect of that so
more is not necessarily better is what
I'm hearing correct I think sorry I'll
take this and you can jump in you know
Chris you often say we can't make our
payers play more
pay more than $10 a day it's it's really
hard to do that and for us it's about
more people engaging than one person
paying $100,000 right it's that combined
with we actually make sure that they
don't play too long like we published
well covet six home five LiveOps
challenges a day they take typically ten
minutes to to complete and we space them
out throughout the day so you can't even
if you play them all like you can't play
more than one at a time and then we
actually tell you to go away like get
back to your life there be another
challenge you know in some way you're
tapping engagement want to leave them
with more that feeling of oh I want to
do more rather than I'm bored I'm gonna
stop for or I'm bored I have to stop
because of something else we want and we
want them to want to come back and you
know be excited for their challenge
results and be excited for the next
thing we have I have you know we have a
great relationship with our community on
covet and I have players who've told me
they have timers for when they know the
next event is gonna start right and I'm
like okay I love that that's great but
there's there's that feeling of wanting
more yep I know you guys said a lot of
this is you know a little bit are a
little bit science in terms of
constantly balancing the look while in
the quant have you ever experimented on
doing more challenges and if so what
happened yes and we still do I mean
sometimes we'll run a like a bonus
challenge and stuff still today but also
when covet was being ever iterated on I
mean they they is actually before my
time
they iterated on many many challenges
like 8 9 10 a day and they settled on
six and that was you know some science
and some some art because they didn't
have the long-term retention data at
that point but it's just what felt right
to them in playtesting you know and it
was a little also a little bit of an
accident because they also you know
would run out these ten and realize like
holy crap we don't have enough people to
make
I'm gonna do now and it just is a nice
rhythm and it's they also spaced them
out so that it's like a snack you know
throughout your day it's all it's
relevant to you no matter where you live
in the globe there's something happening
that you know when you get up and we
talk about it I mean like we could run
out many many many more challenges per
day now but we don't want to and this is
just you know it's a little it's a
typical game design it's not for
everybody but this is what's working for
us so would it be fair to say that in
general you optimize these games for the
masses versus your top 20% of players
absolutely without a doubt like we want
a broad broad player base and payer base
because you know if you if you take out
if you delight a user to the point where
they want to take out two dollars five
dollars they're more invested in the
game they've you've proven something to
them but you know we don't get up to
take out thousands of dollars out of a
few like it's it's about abroad invested
player base they can give you an example
of that so in a covet fashion we have
these hair accessories that everybody
wants and from time to time we do these
$4.99 hair accessories sales and we did
199 seven one and we found that we made
more money with the $4.99 one but more
players bought with the $0.99 one so
we're sticking with the $0.99 one
because we want more players to convert
and engage and begin you know buy more
things later and yeah well we know is
that's actually monetizing revenue over
the long run right because those people
have known best in $0.99 they're more
invested in the platform the hair
accessories did not work for me by the
way so so that's just like the way we
roll let's get let's get some of those
for him and cover it oh yes definitely
the bald is beautiful so no we did have
a bulb yeah so Sarah I have something
that you just said is interesting and
when you are thinking about making
product decisions and so what the
scenario
just described with the $4.99 or sudden
nine cents it sounds like you guys would
even make changes in the game if it was
revenue neutral let's say if it
increased your you know pair if the pair
footprint we do and you know that's not
you know I come from more traditional
gaming background it's it was kind of a
bit of a mind shift for me I'm switching
but there are we do have arguments we
have debates we say you know but we
could make all of this money but then we
also think you know but hey we could
keep we get all these players who will
then make more money for us in the long
run so it is if it is about revenue it's
just about kind of being mindful that we
don't need to make to have a million
dollar day we'd rather have many players
place that we can make more in the end
right so you can have a 50-plus million
dollar here exactly so how do you think
about retaining we've just said like
when users play into the game that means
they're probably more invested in the
game they spend more time in it so
you're actually from a monetization
perspective still optimizing for what it
sounds like long-term engagement but how
do you think about retaining users in
the game that don't want to spend
dollars so we have a lot of different
ways that payers who don't so sorry that
players who don't pay can advance you
know we have rewarding video ads we have
kind of offer walls but in covett we
also have gifting we have these runway
runway rallies where you play with in
your fashion house and there are a lot
of different ways to progress faster you
don't have to play to pay and in fact we
have a large percentage that don't pay
and still enjoy and still have advanced
level 66 and are very happy yeah home to
the same way and we have a borrowing
capacity if you bring a friend in the
same tools and we have a daily gift you
just can't play either as much or maybe
do as high-quality a design as you might
like you really have to make that
decision yeah that sounds like one of
the advantages that you guys have is it
because you have such a broad payer base
you don't actually feel the pressure to
design the game in a way that it's more
focused towards the top 20% of your
users you actually can keep it very open
yes and on top of that I mean if you
actually look
this audience and it's an older female
audience it's also a different approach
it's not a zero-sum game it's you know
it's a positive sum game and you know
it's not about creating a competition
where there's stress and these games are
about creativity and relaxation and
inspiration I mean people call it
Pinterest the game but we do think about
that I mean back in January covet ran or
in an experiment where we loosened our
restrictions the things that you had to
do to enter a challenge and we're like
everybody's like oh no we're gonna not
make money panic attack but design home
was doing so well we had a little bit of
a cushion to be able to try these
experiments and we loosened her
restrictions and engagement went up
revenue stayed the same so you know that
engagement piece I can't emphasize it
enough and there's fear associated with
not doing these things but and it's
fortunate that we did have the design
home cushion thank you Chris but we were
able to run these experiments and we
were able to really see that engagement
matters how do you guys manage against
short-term pressure internally to think
about I'm sorry pressure internally to
think about short-term
KPIs and not prioritize those over this
ideal long-term state I think it's a
struggle I think that it's a mind shift
that you know that we kind of work
through every day because there is
certain pressure to maintain certain
KPIs to hit our goals but what we have
done has worked and the more we continue
to prove that this works the more leeway
we're gonna have to able to say you know
back off this is how is that we're doing
it right I think we have a luxury that
other people may not have when you go do
this because you know this this does
work it does maximize the yield under
the curve like I'm super convinced of it
the great thing about for us is that we
have you know fashion has a 5-year track
record of doing this I'm gonna have the
record year in the fifth year I don't
know of another game that had the record
year in the fifth year and you know so
mostly when we get pressure we can just
sort of
pointed our track record and say this is
what we're doing I'm not gonna say that
works every time sure how closely do you
guys work together even though you're on
separate games like how closely Duke of
InDesign homework together and learn
from each other
lend each other must start you fit out
oh we lend each other money you know
I've only been with crowd star for
almost a year and I look to Chris and
the design home team for advice and
feedback all the time I think that you
know covets a five-year-old product so
design home was really built kind of on
the on the back of what covet was and
took a lot of great learnings from it
but the teams work together all the time
we have the design home and the content
team and the covet content team working
together learning from each other so I
think we we really rely heavily on each
other we have Judy out there who's our
director of product management who works
for design home but who I talk to all
the time and who offers amazing relevant
helpful advice yeah and the truth is I
actually started uncovering fashion like
I ran media and cover fashion I hadn't
been in games it was like drinking
through a firehose definitely changed
the way I looked at the world but you
know fashion is our mother we are built
on her shoulders
you know she fed us while we might
develop the game we took everything that
we liked about it we obviously took our
own take we have a different kind of
economy you know but the two games are
totally intertwined and it's it's we
like each other it's like we we like
having brown bag lunches and talk about
what's working what's not working and
why and lending resources when we need
to I think that's one important thing
about this I've been working in games
for 19 years and crowd star is one of
the first places I've ever truly felt
completely supported like you know with
an absolute family like environment
where you can say hey this is what I
want to do and you're not running it up
the chain 150 times you're actually just
like okay we trust you we believe you go
go for it but the crowd star feeling is
very familial we really support each
other we really care about each other
and you know I'm all about design home
success it's not like we don't have
family squabble we do like
no question about that but I think it's
um I think it speaks to what the game is
when you have a team that's really
supportive of each other yeah I think
that's right and you have different
experience that's too I mean Sarah I am
interested in learning a little bit more
because of your background in gaming I
mean you've mentioned that you had to
have this kind of big mind shift when
you you came to sick of it
one one the first times I met Chris I
said you know it would be so great
because I'm obviously coming from a
gaming perspective if there were timers
or there was some gotcha or at this and
this and he said well I don't know
that's not that's not for us and so like
how how drastic was that mind shift for
you coming from the gaming world
extremely drastic I mean gotcha and
timers and things like that work they
they make money they make revenue they
are you know and I and I come from you
know mobile gaming when it was in its
infancy and those are the things that
work but we have a different kind of
audience we have a different kind of
game we're really toeing the line
between game and app and it's important
for us and it was a shock for me it was
like okay I have to unlearn this I came
in like bubbling with all these ideas
and Chris and I like in one of our first
meetings I was like Chris we could do
this and this and this and it was like
slow down there hang on your ideas are
great and we're not gonna do gotcha but
I think it I think it's something that
it's not the only way I think that there
are a lot of ways to have successful
product it actually speaks to a lot of
our quoi
okay so we have quant coming out of our
years and we have I mean Judy sitting
right there I mean Jeannie like is the
smartest person on the planet right and
and we are definitely run by our data
there's no question about it
but what a koala set is what women love
what our users love about us is that you
know and we actually divide them into
four different actually in your case six
six different player types and what's
important to them and you know what's
important to them all of them know
stress like relaxation infinity
inspiration so like everything we do
like when we say okay like we can make a
million dollars this month okay well
does it add stress you know is inspiring
is it creative because if it isn't it
doesn't go like it just doesn't
go if it is great let's do it it's
amazing that's really unusual be able to
stick theories or values like that night
but it's like it works for the business
like it's it's it's not altruism it's
like really good business one question I
wanted to ask you because it's something
that I think is interesting for the
style famous you guys makin because my
colleague moonlit I know talked about
this earlier and one of the things we're
seeing in the games industry right now
is an increase in exploring and
subscriptions so it's description
something that you guys have ever
thought about offering or do you have I
like opinions about subscriptions and
mobile games in general so I can't speak
to the past what they've thought about
before but we're definitely thinking
about subscriptions I think that you
know there are a lot of great talks
earlier this morning there I think that
we need to think about them in a
different way we definitely are you know
in fact I have a meeting about this this
week but we need to think about how they
work for covet fashion and design home
because what works for one type of game
is not necessarily going to work but I
think subscriptions has a ton of
possibilities I think there there are
ways that we could explore it maybe with
in real life stuff tied into our
products so I don't know what that looks
like I think there's a great future for
we were just committing over here on
well boom that was talking like okay
maybe we need to think about this in a
different way and maybe there's
something that we as a very different
entity can bring to the table that takes
those elements but also adds other
elements into it and you know what it's
frightening at first to think about it
like oh you know I got a good business
like I don't want to cannibal I said
like don't screw it out don't screw it
up don't screw it up but you know we're
we are a company that takes chances and
I think we we might talk about a unique
take on it nice use of the word kept it
saying I was that was great okay let's
switch gears and do lightning rounds
because I think we have a couple minutes
left and but I have some good questions
that I have stored here and so lightning
Rams ready I wish I could limit your
answers to like words like three words
each to make it harder but let's not
really words each no no please green I
said that first right here
we'll design home have its first AR
integration if ever next year in
selective settings okay how many games
real crowd star have live in 2021 more
than three what's the one thing you wish
you knew and a year ago and subsequently
did differently this one's easy
I wish I put more energy and more focus
into recruiting because we're growing
really quickly and it's really hard and
sometimes especially when you're doing
live ops the like lay down the track
right right before the train goes over
it and if you in the unity engineers are
in the crowd meet me at the bar
analysts do just about anybody actually
yeah same questions so what's one thing
you wish you knew a year ago that you
would do differently um you know it's
hard for me to say to have a different
answer than that but I wish that we had
done our covet fashion personas earlier
so you know I wish that we had been able
to really deep dive on who our players
are earlier than we did because it's its
effect we're having a record year it's
incredible and I think if we knew then
what we know now we could have last year
could have in a record year to also name
another game developer that you admire
Network I admire I think play works for
the success and roblox for their
innovation have you or anyone you know
ever bought furniture out of design home
yes yes including my wife what about
clothes from covet yes including myself
alright great when you go into a store
you're like that's our brand yeah and
then you buy it
it's true it's useful learning part of
the hook
exactly okay partying advice Chris if
you could offer other game developers
one piece of advice when it comes to how
they approach new game design what would
that be I think it's write a value
proposition
I think games universally try to solve
the value proposition of I'm bored but
if you can entertain people and tie it
intrinsically to their life outside the
game that's defensible that's totally
different it's additive you know it may
not be curing cancer it might not be
Mother Teresa's work right but it is
additive it's not what other people are
doing and you're competing on a
different different plane knowing what
you know now and for game developers who
are trying to pursue more meaningful
engagement or more sustainable
moderation strategies and do you have
any tactical advice create a
relationship with your players people
who actually play the game think about
the emotions you want them to have while
they're playing and as Chris said the
emotion you want them to have when they
put the game down and have that be your
North Star and focus on that
relationship with the player that can be
measured I mean it can be measured
qualitatively well awesome thank you
guys so much for doing this with me
today I hope everyone feels like they
learned something I have one more thing
to say what I really like about it it's
like we're doing something very
different and it's clear to me Emily and
moonlit that you have gotten what we've
done you've been a champion for this and
it's it's like the best I think it's
important to show that you can be
different and extremely successful and
so thank you so much for joining us
today thank you
[Applause]